it's not a conspiracy - it's anidiocracy
honestly that's what it is
like it's a bunch of guys that wear nice suits and
have nice haircuts patting each other in the back
saying aren't we all so ****ing smart & being wrong
year after year after year after year after year
no this is the thing i think about a lot and um
which is basically kind of economic
conspiracy theories um that are driven by
the internet sometimes by youtube
the first thing i want to say is look
the situation we are in is bad i'm 100% aware of
that and the situation that we have put a lot of
people especially young people but not just young
people in is really bad these people they don't
know how they're going to ever be able to support
family how they're ever going to be able to afford
a decent home increasingly they don't even know
how they're going to pay the food and bills right
and at the same time the information
that they've been given on the media
is confusing it's not clear very often in my
opinion it's flat out wrong you know i talk
about it again and again 450 billion pounds got
given to the rich in the last three years from the
government an enormous enormous amount of money
and you should expect that that will push prices
up and cause crises of inequality and of living
standards and of inflation for ordinary people
that's actually not super complicated we've spoken
about on the channel no one on the news is talking
about it so if this is the context you're in you
can understand why people are going to be like
oh my god this is like a conspiracy theory
the information is being kept from us
so i want to talk a little bit about
the situation and the situation is in in
in many ways is worse right the the cold truth of
the matter is these guys are not smart enough to
make a conspiracy theory listen i've worked in
economics for a long time okay i've worked in
one of the biggest investment banks in
the world i studied at the london school
of economics (LSE) i studied at Oxford
i've been in around the media now
it's not the case that these guys know
what's happening and are hiding it from you
these guys are clueless they are justmaking
it up as they go along like seriously like
when they said at the beginning of the crisis that
they thought house prices will come will collapse
and then when they said they thought they'd
be a really aggressive bounce back because of
demand pent-up demand was the phrase they believe
all that stuff they believe all that stuff
and the truth is this is what happens this is what
happens right something happens and these guys say
oh my god what is going to happen somebody just
shouts a story thing out like oh well an idea well
there's going to be pent up demands so we're
going to have a big bounce back and these guys
just write it because they have to write you know
what i mean they're not even stopping to think
am i right? am i wrong? that the truth is like
thisis the blind leading the blind here you know
we shouldn't live in a world where a 24 year
old kid can walk into one of the biggest banks
in the world and be the best trader in the world
at that bank but we do live in that world because
even on the trading floors and these guys work the
longest hours have the best information have the
best incentivization scheme normally are the best
qualified even there most people have got no idea
what they're talking about and i think ultimately
what this comes down to and we've spoken about
this in a video before is this problem of why
do all of the best jobs go to rich kids you know
ultimately you know i was speaking to somebody
from the Observer and i said to him look your
newspaper is based in London how many kids do
you have in your newspaper who talk like me?
none, right none and you know i worked in
the skyscraper just over there this is we've
been filmed in east London i worked in the
skyscraper just over there somebody asked me
on the trading floor that's an interesting accent
where are you from you know what i mean right
what does that tell you about how we are using
ourbest and our brightest and our smartest kids
you know it's 10 million people in the city and
you can't find a single ordinary person to work
in the newspapers or work in the skyscrapers right
we've developed a system where we basically funnel
kids from rich families into private schools
and elite jobs without ever really stopping to
ask are these guys any [__] good and listen i
can guarantee you in the majority of cases these
guys they know how to look smart they know how to
talk smart but they never started thinking once in
their lives they just walked into these spaces
you know what i mean so then the end result is
it's not a conspiracy it's a it's a [__]
idiocracy honestly that's what it is like it's
a bunch of guys that wear nice suits and have nice
haircuts patting each other in the back and saying
aren't we all so [__] smart and being wrong year
after year after year after year after year and i
almost wish it was a conspiracy because the truth
is in a way more horrific than that which is just
there's kids all over the city that are smarter
than the guys in those newspapers and in those
skyscrapers and they're being wasted wasted
um and then if you are you know someone who
actually figures it out which is not easy to do
right because you know the stuff you learned at
university and the guys who taught university
are kind of done you have to work out yourself
basically if you do work out then these banks will
pay you a million pound data to shut the [__] up
you know what i mean so then the end result
is it's not a case of conspiracy it's simply
a case of very wealthy people can afford the best
resources and that includes the best analysis and
somebody like me can get paid a million pounds
a year to work in them skyscrapers but i choose
to tell people for free on youtube because i
want people to know what is going to happen so
they can stop it because what is going to happen
is going to be a disaster for ordinary people so
it's not conspiracy this is simply a case of look
watch the video what is well the rich people own
everything they have all the income they can buy
the best resources the best analysis realistically
do you think the best economists on the world are
going to be talking on the bbc news why the [__]
would they? they could make so much more money
working for the skyscrapers you know what i mean
so in reality it's not about conspiracy it's
simply about rich people trying to get richer
buying the best resources buying the best
knowledge and that means ordinary people
are not going to get good resources for free
and i think that's why it's that's why i think
it's so important that i do this as somebody
who was one of the best paid economists i give
the people good information because people in
the city the best people in the city they know
this is happening they know this is happening but
they're bought into it they're well paid to do it
and they feel that they can't stop it and
whether i can stop it i don't know but i
feel like i deserve to at least try and people
deserve to to be told what's happening so um
my concern with these conspiracy theories is they
get people to be too negative and they get people
to be angry but the only way we win this is ifwe
get people to be positive and if we get people
to come together you know these conspiracies
drive division they drive people apart and
they force people into sort of panicked modes
of thinking look - its 70-80-90% of the country
getting [__] here these people just need to come
together turn around and say no and this will stop
and that is a question of people
coming together so it can happen um
but you need good information you need good advice
and you need something positive to get behind so
um i'm trying to do that i'm trying my best to be
that so if you like the information you're getting
tell your friends tell your family um and
let's make something positive happen because
because positive change is possible
man that's why i do this keep watching
because we are draining the resources
of this economy and giving it to the
super rich who do not pay any tax
yeahhe's my boy man he's my boy
i like to see a billionaire just take the mask
offfor once and just directly rob everyone